vous voulez partir votre propre podcast
vous voulez à mener celui que vous avez
déjà un autre niveau
ça tombe bien on loue le studio sf ce
merveilleux studio dans lequel je suis
présentement et dans lequel également on
enregistre le sans filtre podcast parmi
tant d'autres la plupart du temps ce qui
empêche les gens de sauter dans
l'univers du podcast est en croissance
constante c'est le manque de
connaissances techniques et aussi le
manque de matériel bien qu'à cela ne
tienne dans le studio sf on loue le
studio avec tout le matériel donc tous
les micros tous les caméras si vous
voulez faire une version vidéo de votre
podcast et ça vient aussi avec notre
technicien extraordinaire nicholl
nicholl qui va vous guider dans votre
projet c'est probablement la personne au
québec qui écoutent le plus de balados
indépendant parce qu'il y ait derrière
la console surtout les balados qu'on
enregistre au studio sf dont il va se
faire un plaisir de vous accompagner
dans ce processus là si vous voulez plus
d'information au sujet de la location du
studio écrivez nous à sans filtre
podcast à commercial gmail.com
une production du studio sf bio venus au
sans filtre et le podcast on parle de ce
qu'on veut avec nos invités date site je
suis de plantes avec moi ps quand on est
en mode confinement chaque pièce ouais
on est dans mes compliments depuis sept
semaines le sens peut-être 9,2
annonceurs sur le sans filtre
premièrement on a mais pas trop où me
free c'est de l'eau d'érable 100% bio
évidemment cet égard si une compagnie
québécoise en ce moment les gabbana
cieux un col à flot par contre c'est
dommage on peut pas y aller parce qu on
est coincé chez nous étonnons même et
autrui offre la livraison 20% de rabais
sur leurs livraisons allaient en
utilisant le code promo en cabane et
comment vendre à court terme d'années
ensea bea m axa et du vin un chiffre
tout ça en deux mots en majuscules qui s
adonnent
livraison c'est un produit que depuis
qu'on a collaboré avec eux et je les
utilise principalement quand je vais au
jam pour courir parce que c'est de la
balle il des bonnes électrolytes il ya
un peu de glucides lents et beaucoup
calories c'est parfait pour ceux en ce
moment évidemment vous pouvez pas les
huitièmes par contre s'ils allaient
courir dans la rue veulent rester actifs
pouvaient faire dit jim d'hommes tchèque
suède et weening chez vous à l'intérieur
fait que mes potes lui à l'échec et sa
compagnie québécoise on vit travers ça
ce serait avec contenant 100 %
recyclable guillot toute l'équipe
merci la gagne ne met pas tout et alleo
du bol site web j'imagine que si vous
incluez mais bon tu es sur google vous
allez tomber direct dessus donc merci la
game & boch sinon et on est également
commandité par vegan mais pas le plâtre
de garder vos places vous savez c'est
mon entreprise que j'ai parti que j'ai
cofondé on offre en ce moment des mets
surgelés en livraison ne ressasse
tourner de bord rapidement
donc on ne réussit enfin à prague libres
sont capables de livrer les blocs
jusqu'à chez vous pour qu'il reste
encore assez froid pour être mis dans le
congélateur
un peut commander sur triple wmp
policiers
je sais qu'on en a envoyé à notre
réussite et cette semaine qui alors à
doris donc allé voir sur ce site leur
préfèrent les mesures partout au québec
puis on donne 25 % de tous les profits
on voudrait acheter en fait des blocs on
va donner aux professionnels de la santé
centres hospitaliers universitaires de
montréal donc le chemin pour les aider à
combattre au front
dans ces moments de crise donc il est
très bon double vie - bnpp points 6e
pour vous commandez les plaques qui
c'est pour une bonne cause puis ça nous
encourage aussi
donc merci pour ce synode hameçonné par
cas s'il savait ou podcast on aimerait
inviter nos invités coup de coeur alors
que les retours de catherine brunet
aujourd'hui il est déjà venu une fois
puis qu'on avait bien aimé discuter avec
elle alors c'est une première expérience
un confinement en vidéoconférence je
pense que c'est quand même bien et il
souhaite la qualité sonore est pas
optimal comme d'habitude mais on fait ce
qu'on peut avec les moyens qu'on a
avec 96 par le faux nom de parler des
sondés comme ans qui vivait son
confinement
qu'est ce qui a fait de ses journées
essayé puis on a parlé de la situation
réfléchis un petit peu sur qu'est ce qui
se passe en ce moment à quel point que
c'est sans précédent est vraiment
hallucinant on ne me dit pas c'est aussi
pour les gens qui vivent cette cette
situation le ce confinement à l'aide
d'une manière difficile que nous sommes
toutes ont fait partie des chanceux qui
s'en tire quand même poppy alors on a
pensé pour bon courage
puis on a parlé un petit peu de projets
auxquels cateau fait partie
récemment je sais que j'avais écouté ça
sert il faut des postes stratégiques
taxe est lente
il ya également un projet 2000 dont fait
partie également la série sur kraft donc
le jeu monsieur qui n'ont que cinq jours
pour exactement pour toujours plus un
plus un jour avec yannick franques
secret qui est gratuit en ce moment
durant le confinement
on nous a parlé aussi de sa présence au
festival de cannes l'an passé c'est pas
mes conversations avec une personne très
allumées et très intelligente très
intéressante
catherine brunet alors laissez les
commentant participation mais dans les
commentaires ici de réagir justement en
ce moment vive le confinement
une façon individuelle donc écrivez
c'est faire partie soit respectueux je
pense que tout le monde c'est des
moments qui sont tous donc on a fait un
podcast jusqu'au péage comme si konami
ce message sur notre plateforme pétri en
parce que ça intéresse vous abonner pour
quelques dollars par mois et avoir tout
les nos créations
et puis d'ypres entre moi et mon
meilleur ami pays merci bonne écoute
[Musique]
à la fac est partie samedi catherine
brunet annulé boys première éviter ou
limiter comme ceux de nos salons après
le premier navire à s'organiser
on saisit pas tout on ne fait p h pour
spreads qui pige en avant des problèmes
techniques avec lui mais le le ca de
l'accueil s'effectue comme cette
pratique dans le son choix devrait
pratiquer choix des répétitions
générales
on peut semer une libérale devant un
public acquis web musical général devant
public
comment dit on confirme à toi bien
ben bien savait pas désolé mais quand
même bien c'est andré que j'ai jamais
autant parlé un écran de ma vie c'est
comme chez ce témoin j'haïs parle au
téléphone j'aï ce fait cet ami j'aï se
parler à travers un écran mais logique
sommes pas le choix parce que je le fais
ce métier j'haïs je m'ennuie demande je
m'ennuie des croquis comme ça dans mon
davantage pesé que jaillisse helmand
mais finalement je pense j'adore le
monde
c'est fait mais finalement je me suis
rendu compte que je t'ai pas que c'est
vraiment mon jour ce que j'aimais bien
drôle manquer
je m'ennuie de la mettais dans le sens
j'habite quand même avec un colloque
avec mon chum ça que ça voltige pas de
tout seul mais quand même si je sens que
ça me sens que ça me manque mais c'est
pas grave le team organise puis gelé
d'élite qui je fais du ménage fait à
manger puis comme tout le monde le dit
comme j'ai parlé à une coupe de
personnes je fais des lives une couple
de fois mais les gens sont encore piqué
ce qui représente encore je mange comme
vraiment le comme tout le monde je me
promène en bobettes chine où puis-je
fait mon chien dit et on fait rien de
tout ça je pense que biskris d'excusés
il avoue un nom si je pense je me suis
dit comme je me suis d'ailleurs je
mettais des recettes le saut dans votre
livre ph il faut que j'essaye le
lacement mais ouais parce que puis on
dirait que j'ai trouvé ce satisfaisante
faire un peu de blues puis d'en avoir
pour la semaine puis me trouver bonne
dans la boîte si je suis comme acquis et
il les portions anorexique je me dis
qu'il fallait que je fasse le plus
souvent c'est clair mais ça c'est en
plus en plus dans les jours qui on est
on est coincé chez nous puis que
l'épicerie c'est pas comme tu peux pas
là l'épicerie m6 favorable de pale ale
souvent moi je me retrouve à cuisiner
vraiment avec comme à vis des égarements
gilles way exactement qu'est ce ça
traînait depuis fort longtemps le fait
qu est ce que je peux faire et que ça
plaise pas fait c'est décidé mieux ça
j'imagine que je ne l'espérais qu'un
savoir terminer sauveur estime ben
j'espère c'est que j'espère c'est comme
j'espère que c'est au moins six côté
positif le vent nous reste et puis quand
c'est une rocheuse genre la marde disent
en outre aux tempi le ça faisait deux
jours que l'on n'a que j'en avais fait
du strip i jah interdisez mon job c'est
mon coloc de de manger les poches et
comme c'est pour lui sert de shoot
mpeg-2 jours tard sa maille en tout
moisi
j'ai vraiment vécu un gros gros deuil
l'éthique tout en expliquant perdu
vigueur hier imaginez la pointe de
l'iceberg de ckoi et d'activation deux
ailes mais pour vraiment j'ai dit j'ai
des amis qui travaillent aux autres de
l'autre côté qui faisait le love love
story et des commercialisateurs petit
moteur pizza sur l'équipe de love story
puis j'ai un ami qu entre autres mon ami
félix qui me disait il dit je me sens
exactement comment leur star il c'est la
même chose de donner toutes les love
franchement pas que j'imagine que ça
s'applique à l'occupation de vapeur que
vous vous étiez dans des lieux
paradisiaques avec une piscine pigera
jim puis comme sept autres personnes
mais je sais pas si c'est pérou c'est
mieux en fait l'essai
toute personne qui ça y est c'est
l'autre question mais tu sais quand tu
dis on parle pas juste un drame
après ça c'est que tout devient de
vienne et g
mais c'est vrai que les gens vont
comprendre un peu plus que vous avez
vécu mais je suis pas celui qui vole pas
d'agent chambly ou quoi je ne sais pas
s'ils vont le faire
belfort à terrebonne comme la saison
parce qu'en ce moment ça s'arrête à
cayenne bah ouais c'est ça mais c'est en
ce moment c'est de la frime preuve déjà
retiré techniquement la plupart des
temps et des jeux sont déjà en train de
scander les locations ces personnes si
comme étant concentrés qu'ils doivent
atteindre au stand by exhorté m moi j'ai
dit prêt d un seul homme
parce que j'avais pas de creux
d'entracte elle vraiment qui
recommençait mois mais me tournage
commençait genre juillet-août métier
même le on sait pas quand exactement
qu'est ce que vous jouiez août et
peut-être qu'avec les gens il s'est
passé quoi qu'est-ce que tu va se passer
avec sa mousse qui m'a fait pas c'est
qu'elle est telle et 2004 par mois le
que ben si c'est pour une période de
quatre mois
c'est qui qui dit ok fac pam à quatre
mots il prévoit que je pourrai
probablement pas travailler je pensais
que c'était pas beaucoup dans le sens
que j'ai comme si ça continue moi je
quand même négative le non sens que j'ai
mieux imaginer que ça va durer un an
je pense pas le style s'est vraiment
passé les pronostics mais j'aime mieux
imaginer que ça va durer vraiment
vraiment vraiment longtemps comme ça si
ça dure quatre mois ou deux mois mais je
vais être content mais moi je te restait
quatre mois à partir du mois d'avril
sasaki avril mai juin juillet tabarnak
paquet ouais mais c'est un domaine
jusque là nous avons commencé c'est
débile ces pauvres et on en parle un peu
demain samedi à chaque matin au réveil
qui voudrait que je crois pas encore si
on dirait que c'est une espèce de flou
constat aujourd'hui est ce que vraiment
on est en train de vivre collectivement
c'est moins les dix premiers matins je
me réveillais puis moi je fais souvent
des rêves de femmes demandent le genre
zombie de genre à aimer pour faire cela
mais je me réveillais je suis un
cauchemar prenez conscience que non
c'était la réalité trois fois la
troisième fois c'est encore la même
chose aux caprices et castrés va
s'élancer a dit moi je pense qu est ce
que je sais pas moi ça fonctionne pour
moi mais je conditionne sa rouge accord
met dans le pétrin denim et plus me dire
que ben si c'est ma nouvelle réalité
c'est ça ma vie je fais à manger je fais
le ménage m'entraîne chez nous puis
j'écoute bizarre frappé g7 pas penser au
futur parce que sinon je trouve se
trouvait parole de me dire comme je
pourrai mais en même temps aussi je
pense que c'est bien et je pense que
c'est moi ça m'a vraiment mis beaucoup
de mépris village d'en face
ouais tu en quoi le temps par exemple
pas été la liberté la liberté en fait
tout simplement
ne serait-ce qu'une la liberté de daleo
jure t on à delhi b6 l'ordre juste
d'aller mettons à l'épicerie l'été je
dirais transmettons aux prisonniers qui
ont perdu cette liberté là qu'ils ont
perdu ce privilège leur métier ne sera
ainsi que de voyager d'abord l'argent
pour voyager d'avoir tout pour aller au
restaurant pour sortir ou au théâtre au
cinéma
toute cette espèce de rapport et à
l'argent et à la la liberté que ça donne
on dirait que ça m'a vraiment fait
commun ça m'a vraiment fait un choc
parce que si je me dis oh mon dieu je
pouvais voyager dans les six prochains
mois puisque comme à emmen y ait des
gens qui n'ont jamais voyagé de leur vie
puis je dis je le suis plus conscient de
ses privilèges le mais on dirait que
l'europe était confrontée à ces images
inc
il ya beaucoup de choses que j ai
effectivement privilège j'imagine que
privilège c'est le silmo pour ce la même
chose qu'on comprend peau acquis dans
notre vie ouais
dernièrement je réfléchissais attire
toutes les
les événements ou les événements
rassembleurs par exemple tout ce qui est
spectacle tout ce qui est un festival
match de sport
est-ce que ce truc gros plus d'individus
avec un intérêt commun pour célébrer cet
intérêt lotie puisqu'elle dans la vie de
tous les jours on on prend pour acquis
qu'ici en amérique du nord on peut fax
si tu veux acheter bien pour le canadien
la chef dit tu vas tripes et avec tous
les fans du canadien sur ce type mais le
mois maintenant mais match pense utile
le festival d'été québec le mage avec ce
que j'avais vraiment envie d'aller voir
will the guns de chine d'italie allait
rédiger le recours contre le système
avec plug and de tripes comme moi
laitiers qui le je me dis et s'est pas
fait c'est le festival d'été il loin
faire pis même que je paye pas capable
en ce moment dans la situation qu'on est
où est ce que je vois courir dehors il
fait des détours de cinq mâts est au
tour du monde pour pourquoi les croisés
je me dis que puisque qu'on est loin de
se le dise qu'on prenait pour un kit
comme elle c'est vrai malade cet été on
retourne sur le groupe est un des
centaines de milliers des dizaines de
milliers quoi les tripes et ami intime
et on oui jordi gros festivals c'est sûr
qu'elle veut tant je veux juste fermer
mon store parce que c'est clair
[Musique]
au lieu de passer même dès lors on peut
même pas se rassembler gens plus que 3
seulement des amis sociaux ne pourrait
pas y penser qu'en juillet au festival
d'été on pour se rassembler 80 ml sur
les plaines d'abraham
j'ai tout dit des petites d'autres
faudrait faudrait que la coupe soit
morte à ce moment là où qui avait
enrhumé douche pourquoi mettez qui dit
comme c'est sûr mais trop juste les
shows en effet s'il fou quand on prend
le prenaient pour acquis le comme on
sait jamais dit à amman et on pourra
plus aller boire de spectacle je sais
pas quoi vous êtes à moi j'avais des
billets pour un film en langue c'est
moins un gros événement mais sebelius il
est quand même fou mais comme disait de
moussy juste de voir ses amis juste de
pouvoir être quatre autour d'une table
puis de jouer à un jeu de société puis d
c'est quelque chose que jamais je me
serais dit oh mon dieu je pourrais
peut-être terme
certes c'est fou mendy ce qui le plus
fou c'est qu'est ce qu'on vit dans ses
caméras sur mana c'est que tout le monde
sur la planète dans le fond pratiquement
vie ce qu'on vit en ce moment ses pieds
toutefois une journée qui reste sa
maison petit fait pas grand chose
puisque trois de fait le ménage c'est à
manger il ya un sentiment de culpabilité
de hg pas en fait de quoi mais là c'est
comme toujours c'est six points d'avancé
et pour purge les seniors parce qu il
riait tout mais ça où tu le vois je me
sens quand même pas parce que maintenant
les journées où je joue à ces mesures
animal crossing sur ma switch.com je
fais vraiment rien puissant vraiment à
rien comme moi j'ai quand même le
sentiment c'est le gérard du cinéma mon
anxiété de performance et pas juste lié
à ma job est lié à moi en fait
complètement comme je pourrais être en
train d'apprendre une langue je pourrais
est en train d'apprendre à faire que
l'enfant je présenterai de genre et je
pourrais tout est en train de faire
quelque chose on dire dans ma tête c'est
là que je réalise que c'est peu juste
par rapport à ma job dispose jusqu'au
c'est juste quelque chose dans ma tête
qui me dit tout le temps que je pas
assez ou que je sais quoi cette chose
utile mais ça je pense qu'on est toutes
un peu je pense que notre société nous
rappeler notre société occidentale nous
a tous rendus un peu comme seul comme
faut tout le temps être efficace qui est
en train de faire des affaires mettez
même si la planète est en train de rien
chris et moi j'étais encore en train de
me dire que je pourrai est en train
d'apprendre l'espagnol comme ben ouais
apprendre l'espagnol pourra les genres
voyager quand la folle dans deux ans si
comme mais ont pu profiter sa maman
allaite il est comme si françois des
messieurs legault
mais québec se repose le premier
ministre c'est le frisbee dans ce québec
c'est en plus mais les gars vraiment
tout à côté les gendarmes puis si on
peut en même temps ce mettre sur pause
qui apprend à être capable de se mettre
sur pause souci c'est bon c'est un bon
prétexte un bon moment pour faire ce
seppi a comme juste se reconnecter avec
ckoi à être un humain
betty longs mois moi je constate qu'ils
étaient super extrêmement raison c'est
juste que je sais qu'il ya des gens ce
moment que c'est positif nous je parle
merde que moi je me considère chanceuse
parce qu'il est en ce moment j'ai pas de
problème d'argent et que je peux comme
qu'ils les piges au jeu vidéo pu me
poser des questions sur comment moi puis
sur une pause puis messi chic et des
gens ce moment qui sont sa grosse
panique piquer leurs vagues c'est pour
ça je pense on a chacun notre vague puis
on est chanceux je pense faut quand même
considérer qu'on est chanceux de pouvoir
voir ça comme une poésie non pas genre
je serais pas capable de payer mais bill
pour la prochaine a mis ses pas nous on
est touché un petit peu parce c'est lé
l'arrêt complet là dessus on ne fermait
studio en trop depuis ni les contrecoups
europe qui malgré tout ces jeux des jeux
pas en train de me demander comment je
paye mon loyer
dans deux jours c'est qui se dit bien
4,6 d'imaginer parce que c'est sûr qu'en
ce moment il réellement des gens qui
s'ils ont au le revenu nécessaire pour
continuer à vivre si ceux ci dessus ce
qu'une fois que tu réalises sur le
service que nous ayons on vit la crise
mais j'étais encore capable de mettre
des souliers d'aller courir d'europe
c'est pas la fin du monde c'est me cite
si j'avais en plus deux comme l'espèce
de sentiments d'arrêter ma vie pendant
un stage avant plus l'espèce de de
pression complètement une scène ne pas
pouvoir nourrir ma famille ne pas
pouvoir avoir un toit puis mettez vous
oui mais tant pour les travailleurs
autonomes comme un et deux milliards par
mois mais temps pour te manquions qui
ont besoin de ce fonds à 2004 par mois
mais devant moi ça descend mettre des
mois comme cela avec deux enfants le
petit c'est exact mais tant le 2000
comme moi ça vole ça va vraiment être
correct mais je dis si j'avais deux
enfants comme tu dis je te mangerais
relancer l'emploi
c'est stressant magie ville comme ça
c'est le foot et fausse des caisses faut
penser à la chaîne le ti la chaîne il
sont puis il commence à être correct et
on a quand même suivi d une voyante des
mesures à 6 très exact est donc dans le
processus aussi ouais on n'a pas gagné
sur ce panorama ceci pour tout l'est m
toutes les fois où est ce que je suis
moyens d'accord avec le gouvernement du
québec entre m je pense est unanime ça a
été vraiment une gestion de grease
impeccable on installe ses filles quand
par sa trame classique hommes
et lui ça fait par le métro jalil veut
pas le voir il ferme les yeux riz et y
avez vous vu parce que à mon dieu
pourquoi je me regarde simplement sans
halogène et ya le voyons le jeu par mais
bon ça peut te sens pas du tout par ac
10 09 de new york et y a demandé d'avoir
des ventilateurs pour dans le cacao puis
et ont demandé des ventilateurs puis des
respirateurs la maison blanche située 1
bd comme une thèse il vit trouvé qu'avec
ebay est avec lui puis que le gouverneur
avait été irrespectueux a sonné gore sa
quille envoyé 4 100 respirateurs alors
que le lecteur on a besoin de gens 3000
puis tu as bien comme fête bat ces
suspects de même ça fonctionne le défunt
avec moi je fais toi puis c'est ce qui
ce jeu comme douvier genre déjà qu'ils
sont en train de mourir lentement plutôt
petit et ses débuts puis dernièrement
six organs genre sont à compte twitter
le puits y alliez ya genre d'aller le
pin mamane crise et qu'ils ont on est
dans le pays au moment de crise
2 de l'avis de tout le monde qui vit à
soi même puis sur son compte twitter
'tweet' les rétines de télévision de ces
speech dans le bureau ovale il dijon
norwich et 8.5 millions pilotes qui se
vendait savez ce que c'est des
dissidents mais comme doute parce que
tout le monde et chez eux n'ont rien
d'autre à face est ce que tu te regardes
tu est un magnet était à ses débuts bien
on a parlé de notre sens en ce2 s'il y
avait un doute que ce gala était pas
apte à être président des états unis
tyrol d'autres le l'oeil +2 tandis que
c'est l'appellation grise au monde de
toutes les leaders mondiaux la pire
gestion des crises baisse parce qu'elle
est ce sinistre adultes
la nouvelle paire place moment pour les
choristes new york cc les 14 c'est ça
n'a pas de bon sens que tu viennes
expliqué cindy la montre juste que
l'école est complètement dénuée de
capacité d'avoir de l'empathie pour
contre swap ces all with about résultat
si c'est du gros narcissisme le peuple
et je sais qui tu ne t'es pas de
castille j'avoue qu'on reprend ses
bourdes chance dans les commentaires il
ya des gens qui n'aiment pas ça mais
alors pourquoi ben ya au québec au
québec certaines populations vraiment à
l'extérieur de notre chambre d'écho à
mesure qu'1 qui épaule et lille une
restriction vraiment grand des
politiques d'immigration qui pourrait
manquer beaucoup monkey qui endossent
des politiques de charm par rapport à
ceux qu'il côtoie des déjà kiki qu'il
endosse un peu partout dans le monde et
jean conservateur c'est juste là je peux
pas en format boîte et non pas parce que
je veux dire si tu si tu t'intéresses
moindrement à la politique en général
tu as beau être d'accord avec ces
politiques d'immigration metok terrassé
ses bords je me faire envoyer des dites
merde mais donc tu es vraiment de droit
qui était quand génération méthodes
identiques contre l'immigration décor
d'une migration de masse c'est se
mettant le tabac
malgré tout si tu t'intéresses -
vraiment à la politique américaine
je peux pas être d'accord avec toi mon
général tu es jeune tu peux pas
l'appuyer
ne serait-ce qu juste pour se cela dit
après il ya des gens qui basent leur
politique sur des petits points comme
sur le taiseux des rues il ya des gens
super un aspect précis qui leur tient
correctement le tir il ya tellement de
gens qui on trippe sur le gaultier
depuis depuis certaines affaires c'est
vraiment très précises le moi je me
rembarre cul dans ces affaires le parce
que je me suis longtemps fait [ __ ] ma
gueule sur les super coq sociaux
par rapport à la loi 21 mai soit
important peu importe sa prise de
position
soit faire [ __ ] la gueule ces réseaux
sociaux camier pas des débats de façon
de s'en sortir
non si c'est exact moi ce qui me fait
rire c'est que les gens aussi sur comme
j'aime ta gueule toi tu est une
comédienne dont ne pas venue de ton avis
politique comme betata photo de profil
c'est un saint homme
pourquoi toi ton opinion politique et
plus tu aurais plus le droit de le dire
que moi parce que je suis comédienne
oui des fois les gens sur internet ne
font pas c'est off c'est d'offres la
politique sur internet
c'est tough parler de ça c'est tough
d'en parler en personne avec des tapas
famille c'est magique car il ya un
filtre de médecins du monde peuvent se
cacher derrière une photo de profil d'un
show qui est utile ou à la pression
c'est ce qui crée des conflits belle
foyers au québec mais sur internet sera
punie parce que vous débattez vous avec
avec les gens se mettaient réponse
réponse réponse réponse à tout ça des
fois où sur twitter sur twitter sur
facebook des commentaires
mais pour tous les x oui mais j'ai
réalisé que me rappelle pas qui me fait
réaliser south ici un article que j'ai
lu ou enfin parce que je sais pas d'où
ça vient mais je dirais que c'est pas
moi qui ai inventé cette affaire là
intelligent que je m'apprête à 10,1 un
magnet quelqu'un qui me parlait de des
débats sur facebook puis sur les réseaux
sociaux
puis comme quoi quand débat sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est souvent plus un
show qu'autre chose
acte i mettons tu vas commencer à te
bénisse par rapport à quelque chose
pilot tu veux juste essayer de
développer la personne puis à peu de la
bouche et le tipi d'avoir plus
intelligent que la personne taxes
l'autre quelqu'un qui écrit quelque
chose sur elle
sur facebook le j'ai commencé à
commenter le la personne répond dupe le
jeu tu arrivé pour y répondre quelque
chose dans le genre je me suis dit
normal on attend cette personne je laime
j'aurais le goût qu'on aille savourer
des bonheurs mais en privé lui en privé
puis comme des fêtes
on s'est entendu un quinze minutes on
s'est parlé on s'est compris on a
échangé nos points 7 et pertinents alors
que je 6 si j'avais continué à échanger
en dessous de son statut s'arrête à
ramener
le port est magnifique comme arrêtez-moi
de m'obstiner sur les réseaux sociaux en
public parce que je pense que ça sent
vraiment vous savez j'avais entendu
c'était à radio canada radio qu'il y
avait une étude du piquet dit qu'après
cinq réponses mais on a justement dans
une obstination sur facebook ou aux
autres après cinq réponses c'est
impossible de faire changer l'opinion de
l'autre mais savent que si s'est rendu
jusque là à dire que les deux camps vont
jamais écouté ta guitare avec le
meilleur argument du monde c'est plus ça
dure mon essai à l'appui bien en général
justement les gens qui vont quand même
commenté puis vouloir débattre facebook
de changer l'opinion ne vois pas ma
commentaires après par face à face toit
plus de chance mais encore le de sédhiou
changer de pneus quelqu'un qui dit
forget sur une vidéo filmée temps avec
des amis ou dans un des bottes et je
dire le débat il peut durer une heure là
dans le sens que si tu veux vraiment
contre c'est pas avec un inconnu sur les
réseaux sociaux que tu vas commencer à
changer d'avis lé nom exact c'est quand
même les gens qui insultent ou quittent
ils sont super qui ont le manque de
respect plus tu es comme kim est pour
quoi qu'ils disent chacun baissé mon
opinion jules droit et comme oui mais
pourquoi tu dis ben espace jules doit
tout le temps j'ai le droit qui comme
ben oui je comprends mais dans ce sens
est-ce que tu réalises que pourquoi je
pense à sa place à mettront un christ
c'est bon c'est technique des gens leur
introspection le désert
non mais le pilier aucune prospection
qui donne c'est vraiment genre lotois
yens une dame sur mon facebook qui à
écrire sur mon facebook personnelle
perso vue personnel j'avais vraiment non
jeu sims une femme avec qui chez amis
facebook puis à l'écrit en dessous d'un
truc de radio canada jadis cette
émission avec dégoûtante c'est si pourri
des gens
un truc de même sacré si quelqu'un sait
ce que c'est quelqu'un qui connaît dans
la vie où c'est quelqu'un qui m'avait
demandé comme amis facebook
je pense qu'on avait beaucoup de liens
en commun savait qu'on est amis facebook
puis alex d'une émission le gie équipe
j'ai dit mais vous savez que ça peut
blesser quand même comme commentaire tu
es dans le sens que peu importe si je
suis d'accord ou pas avec vous sur si
l'émission est bonne ou pas du monde y
ont mis beaucoup de monde qui ont
travaillé là dessus du monde tienne
cette émission leur est un réalisateur
une réalisatrice qui vais rien ce qui va
peut-être voir ce commentaire la pie xi
un commentaire qui peut nuancer qui est
inutile
j'ai comme il suit un peu qu'ils étaient
comme ben franchement si cette personne
là de la peine pour ce commentaire est
un commentaire qui veut rien dire c'est
un commentaire inutile si je donne mon
job et qui vu le pro mais d'abord
pourquoi vous l'avez écrit puis au début
était comme un peu fruits
après plusieurs messages à man et à
l'infini par le supprimer et m'a dit je
lis supprimés mais pas parce qu'une
énième ligne homme a le film primé jeter
comme celle à celle avec make de dôme
nomme quand il dit à human ce faire il
va regarder enfin personne la maison je
vais parce mais je ne sache pas ce que
tu me le monde c'est parce que j'ai
décidé mais pas plus sa fille dans la
cave est à nous pas de casser une phrase
mtq on avait eu pu indiquer t elle du
temps et en heures sup le ski kantigui
parce que ça paie sa fille nahla
à oui on ne sait plus qui fait que
victime je goûte à l'équipe et au monkey
qui équipent des massages gratuits le
mettons les rails ses écrits elle est
grosse et elle pu elle-même qu'elle
aille écrite bleus aillent et qu'ils en
privé cette madame le bon jour j'en
rêvais j'envoie commentaire m'a fait de
la peine pour cause et qui se
pis souvent les gens qui vivaient au jeu
je ne voulais pas vous blesser je
m'excuse mais pourquoi tu dis là il ya
des gens qui ont montré qu'ils ont
l'impression qu'ils vivent dans une
autre dimension le que qu'est ce qu'ils
voient à la télévision le train c'est
l'impression que j'ai l'impression qu'au
québec la relation avec l'abbé clair
surtout à mort y ans c'est moins pire
parce qu'à montréal on est habitué de
voir montréal les jeunes malades
maintenant j'en fais partie ont
l'habitude de voir des gens connus c'est
dans good croise le saluent célébrité
ici mais j'ai l'impression qu' aucun cas
tu recevras périphérie un petit peu plus
au québec
la relation avec les gens de la
célébrité j'imagine que c'est et imagine
un peu quand même
c'est brad pitt qui qui qui jappe à
internet ainsi qu'ils viennent d'une
équipe qui gère ces messages à sa canada
les chier mais au québec c'est
certainement la relire ce genre tout le
monde
aucune sérénité au québec sq une boîte
ces réseaux sociaux le aucune pourtant
team et au soir en région montréal ou en
banlieue où les gens sont super
respectueux qui super gentil pis
entrevue moi mon expérience je sais pas
les gens sont peu plus mais je comprends
ce que tu veux dire pour quelle raison
mais ce qui est fou c'est que les gens
méchants pays respectueux c'est juste
sur internet
c'est à dire genre t'es grosse [ __ ]
ultime come on s'est vraiment sur
internet que les gens qui se permettent
heures mais connaissez-vous la page
celui qu'il dit aux agents les photos du
monde avec une bombe on se dit c'est bon
tellement drôle des fois je pleure de
rire si longtemps sans qu'un nom
pochette mais et c'est celle de monsieur
qua non
ces deux banques prennent des
commentaires justement pas ça me fait
penser à sa fille parce qu'ils aiment
années quand elle a fait sa sortie que
elle a les siennes aliments et sur les
réseaux sociaux plai à l'habitude d'une
photo où étaient nus ou dans son club où
j'ai plus qua non
c'est après son clip
il ya des gens qui trouvaient des
commentaires évidemment super et
respectueux qui méchant tu vois celui
qu'il dit la page facebook je pense sur
un compte instagram
ils prennent la photo de profil des gens
qui ont fait le commentaire qui écrivent
le commentaire sur cette photo là c'est
exactement qui a dit le commentaire sauf
que souvent ces gens n'ont pas de bon
sens même du béton c'est tellement drôle
de mettre en parallèle commentaires que
la personne et qu'ils puissent à face
parce que madame ou s'ils sont avec leur
show avec leurs petits-enfants fille si
genres et toutes mangé de dammam de
chameau si j'en déduis par racisme qui
détruit comme au monde mais c'est ça
mais des fois c'est jean notre gardent
leurs photos petit ça pourrait être ma
tante ou sa toile au récit j'avais quoi
c'est maintenant c'est quand tu vois ses
5e année madame kiki comme qu'il est
guéri et comme souvent bibliothèque
laisser genre et à l'écrit et je sais
pas sur quel ton du genre ah si vous
servez à rien et regarde cours de
réseaux sociaux le discours de
bienséance
ça devrait s'adresser aux imposteurs
l'insee qui font les guignols giniès le
aux personnes et aux personnes plus
âgées qui me l'apprendre internet day by
day
si vous avez quelque chose ça va être lu
par quelqu'un qui fout c'est car vous
allez faire un commentaire
les gens ils peuvent le voir oui c'est
pas juste c'est pas 2 pour vous et vos
amis tchèques beaucoup ri réseaux
sociaux là en temps de pandémie on
arrive on n'a pas grand chose de plus à
faire ouais mais je trouve que
en ce moment voudrais que ça va être un
genre de geste édition avec une
journaliste de radio can saguenay qui
m'avait pas son entrevue pourrait
justement les influenceurs qui ont donc
un appel aux jeunes pendant la maison
exact le raisonnement qui a été à
laquelle est arrivée sur la question
c'était de devoir qu'il promet que les
gens soient maires vont réaliser ce que
les réseaux sociaux peuvent avoir de
positif pour la suite des choses c'est
parce qu'en ce moment si ce n'est
pratiquement que par les réseaux sociaux
que les gens se divertissent c ou que
les gens puissent peuvent interagir
il restait à jour c'est que j'ai
l'impression qu'ils croient pas si
vraiment la perception va changer qu'on
va réussir à excuser sans doute plus
pour le positif qui - pour justement
leur aide comme ça c'est ces choses là
je pense que la frontière est remplie
médias
de plus en plus floue j'imagine mais
clairement que cette crise-là avoir
amené j'imagine une nouvelle façon de
voir les la façon d'utiliser les médias
sociaux vous rejoins une certaine
d'aston tu mets autant que les gens
réalisent je pense pas que j'espère vont
réaliser l'importance comme tu dis et
des réseaux sociaux et des gens qui
crient diverses divertissement sur les
réseaux sociaux et au temps comme la
télé la musique c'est les gens qui
disent que les artistes servent à rien
je ne sais pas quels médecins dans leur
pub en ce moment là comme qu'est ce qui
fonde leur journée à porte chez qu'est
internet la télé et film
1 mais aussi j'espère qu'il y ait des
gens sur internet qui font rire mais
qu'est il faut qu'ils varient leur
contenu quoiqu'il baril leur contenu
mais qu'est ce que le band que même moi
je dis moi c'est moi même mois mais un
sorcier
c'est en ce moment je peux rien faire
moi je sais rien faire de mes dix doigts
je sais quoi comme j'écris patent et je
plains pas je fais pas de musique que je
joue si je suis plus limoges
inutile en temps de guerre factice comme
qu'est ce que je peux faire pour me
rendre utile mais j'espère aussi que les
gens mettant justement comme sur les
réseaux sociaux
sa valeur à ouvrir les yeux de ce que je
veux dire mais qui vont trouver un moyen
de renouveler leur contenu ou citer
certaines personnes qui ont un créneau
vraiment vraiment précis pts qui s'est
beaucoup tes des photos de voyages pris
des photos et des photos en général de
produits laitiers je dis oui tu peux
faire ça chez vous mais on s'entend qui
est temps qu'on lui mais il commence à
s'amoindrir là je dirais que j'ai tout
nous donner un coup de pied dans le cul
en fait pour vouloir faire plus je vais
jetter
on ne va pas non mais je pense qu'ils
ont césium ce point quel genre de jeu
devant une personne se fait référence
mais s'est dit mais qui l'attend s'il
met tout à fait mais c'est quand je
parle de toi ce matin et signera dans
gars jouent dans une cité tu le fais
déjà fait
c'est maintenant si les gars veulent se
divertir et énormément le contenu dans
lequel te crie par qui est disponible
ses membres peuvent écouter les heures
et des heures de dirt artistique dans
lequel tu étais à part entière
si vous aussi c'est tout à fait utile en
temps de guerre de s'y colle et semant
utile qu'une photo de voyage dans ce
roman dépotoir avec chris mac comme
superflus ces gens moi je vois des
photos de voyage les seuls feeling que
ça me fait même si les gens sont comme
trop bac machin vraiment ça me fait de
la peine c'est ce que puis deuxième
manche comme
c'est dangereux vous à la société gas uk
aucun moyen qu'une photo de voyage soit
agréable pour moi en ce moment ça me
permet même pas de sortir demain mais
bon c'est pas parce que tu veux dire que
c'est oui à du contenu que les gens
peuvent regarder sûr que quand même
j'aimerais ça pouvoir avoir un talent
tes jouets du monde mettant qui joue du
piano chante au team vous on vous avez
vous avez votre truc vous pouvez le
faire à distance comme moi je lis je lis
comme à tous les quinze lits une
demi-heure de livres c'est georgie une
demi-heure de livres mais comme c'est
vraiment la seule à faire pour l'instant
auquel je à laquelle je peux contribuer
pour faire une différence qui est des
ces facs comme il faudrait que
j'apprenne à jouer d'un instrument mais
comme dit peut-être que ça pourra pas
depuis que je peux aussi servir à rien
puisque pas grave mais mais qui peut au
moins se consoler en disant je te
maquiller plus que j'aime bien sa mort
le monde consomme faux départ or le
monde consomme fait partie des coutumes
il faut de views jean romanet
il ya une reprise de virginie pour avoir
des cotes d'écouté mis au monde ou non
mais bref bref moi c'est drôle ph parce
que on est connecté mon pea stutzmann
aller directement à même place que toi
quelqu'un celui-ci n'est pas non mais
n'a pas où elle a fait tous de manière
différente qui il y en eu qui en est qui
font rire il y en a qui travaillent à
l'épicerie pu y en a qui créent du
contenu sur tou.tv pour que d'autres
personnes puissent regarder ceux pour
qui le sont un peu moins seul parce que
si il y en a qui sont isolées seul hic
sont alimentés moi j'étais avec
quelqu'un j'ai un collègue qui toi tu
étais avec ton show ces il y en a qui
ont besoin absolument de ses contenus de
ce nom
s'ils virent foudre à chacun à chacun
son rôle
je pense faut pas commencer non plus ah
parce que je les ai vus les commentaires
aussi pis moi même je suis ici avec moi
car je vois un commentateur déjà à des
artistes est votre priorité en ce moment
pinana l'arrêté de charlie davies pas si
j'ai envie de faire ce que tu fais parce
qu'ils ont ce sont nos diocèses de
rigueur as tu ne peux pas croire qu'être
consomment bien en ce moment en
quarantaine parce que sinon c'est ce fou
mais c'est ça les gens qui pillent les
artistes fait pas la priorité parmi les
personnes qui a dit combien la priorité
c'est juste que en étant un système
fragile où il y avait déjà pas beaucoup
d'argent puis qu'on ait des gens qui
sont payés crise dans le sens qu'on n'a
pas de salaire régulier puis fax pas une
affaire de priorité c'est une affaire de
bree continue a dit henri kassy son
vivant en temps de pandémie checker du
d'affaires ben on va avoir besoin que de
trois pièces au moins des fois les
relais cammarata pas voir le nombre de
fautes qui est dangereux mais d'ici là
peut-être consommé un petit peu plus de
culture que ce mois ci c'est là que j'ai
fait sur la loi 21 films non mais si
c'est vrai les gens qui sont comme moi
ça c'est tout ce pan le qui me fait rire
les gens qui parlent de culture
québécoise qui sont comme notre culture
québécoise notre culture québécoise
c'est les mêmes gens qui chie sur les
avis de lampes sur les artistes qui
savent pays qui est nécessairement des
biens puis évidemment le fond c'est
grossier pis si on fait un portrait
genre exagéré mais ça reste que si tu
sais pas écrire en français comme
demande
ce programme d'un centre jugement et des
gens qui n'ont pas la chance d'avoir une
scolarité tout d'abord c'est d'apprendre
à lire et à écrire sauf que après vienne
pas me dire ma culture québécoise ma
culture québécoise c'est quoi ta culture
québécoise s'est fêté la saint jean dans
ses pas écrire le français sait pas
parler français mais si tu utilises ddd
des films québécois puis la télé
québécoise piteux taille les artistes
plus de she sur tes comme c'est quoi ta
culture québécoise alors nous ne sais
quoi c'est clair si si
isole la culture québec aux votes
tellement plus loin que le français ces
mots tellement plus loin que la langue
qu'on parle c'est toutes les oeuvres
artistiques confie j'avais jamais pensé
à cela façon que celui de l'exprimer
mais c'est vrai que la plupart du temps
l'espèce de discours radio poubelle et
l'espèce de discours radio poubelle
comme les artistes s'en va rien c'est un
peu mince et un bris lui même personne
qui qui sont tellement fiers de leur
identité et de leur culture mais cette
densité leuze ça le domaine artistique
existe juste mais exactement c'est ce
qu'il comprend pas si ça je me dis il
j'aimerais ça parlait avec ces gens là
puis dire ok mais explique moi qui étais
fier de quoi du sirop d'érable la
ceinture fléchée le quarté comme on
n'était même pas là pour le bâtir le
québec oui nos ancêtres étaient là mais
je dire de quoi t shirts italie les
artistes puis style je suis très très
confuse mois par abbas
c'est vrai c'est une bonne question non
mais c'est quoi ton elle met donc être
un extraterrestre tu descendais way sur
tarbes qui me disaient qu'est bh il
connaît mon ouïe et victor d une saison
encore ta saison 2 au début de ce genre
il pense que on may be monde des
méthodes des foules mais maintenant tu
vas voir ce qu'ils me disent de moins
trois affaires qui représente le mieux
la culture à mon avis à moins de tibro
allemagne ce serait 3 aux lancers francs
heureusement que je lui donnerai promet
que gillet écoute poésie remis jeudi les
échos
le don de jean leloup c'est bon
probablement que je lui dirai aussi eu
viens avec moi checker une patinoire
extérieure ou est-ce qu'il ya douze
jeunes si sky sports jouant le jeu avec
la même passion que je montrerai c'est
trop a peur elle même si j'avais à
montrer notre culture à un
extraterrestre c'est quoi forte tête
netflix je regarde c'est ça le québec
mais moi je pense à ce rêve moi j'ai du
courage il décroît récemment j'ai
commencé à lille le michel tremblay
j'avais lu genre à toi pour toujours ta
marie-lou que ses pièces de théâtre
quand j'étais plus jeune mais j'ai
commencé à lire les chroniques du
plateau mont royal
ça m'a tellement touché parce que j'ai
lu la grosse homme d'à côté d'anciens en
premier je me suis vraiment dit
tabarouette mon dieu si ça ça n'a pas
d'oeil au milan si je vous dis mais
c'est tellement est très sec à notre
culture montréalaise en sorte que pour
moi ça me touche parce que ça se passe
sur le plateau puis j'habite le pire
m'est il est temps je reconnais le
langage de migrants par an je reconnais
le linge sec - les chroniques du plateau
mont-royal de michel tremblay ça serait
une de ces affaires là parce qu'il parle
beaucoup des gens qui viennent de la
région aussi évidemment c'est pas que
montréal
ce à quoi je pense que je lui ferais
genre frère de michel tremblay je leur
ferai voir un film de xavier dolan
probablement ya quelque chose de
vraiment il ya quelque chose qui à mon
avis mais évidemment avec quelque chose
à mon avis qui qui qui est vraiment
semblable en poésie puis momie il ya
comme toute l'espèce de premièrement si
vraiment ancré dans une époque précise
c'est qu'on est tous capables de
reconnaître que c'est pas la même époque
on avait tellement de pour des jeunes
autre ajoute notre génération il m'a dit
les trucs qui sonde anale face mais j'ai
apprécié tout l'aspect à l'amuser
l'espèce de effectivement ce que le gars
sur un québec qui peut toujours beau
message jugé non plus tout ce qu'ils
foutent de l'oeuvre de xavier si c'est
les personnages fn et xavier c'est
peut-être dé xavier le xavier sauf que
ça quand même l'amour l'amour qu'ils ont
pour le québec puis pour ces gens-là
impact puisque c'est des gens qui
connaît piqué il dépeint pas quelque
chose qu'on est potes ayez pas comme
parler du monde
owen signé comme il est comme moi c'est
comme ça ça me fait penser à moi je
connais ces gens là qu'il va parler des
choses qui connaît ça c'est pour ça que
c'est aussi réaliste ou si je pense mais
tu es fou je suppose non mais parce que
tu faisais une affaire de e à qui je
trouve que c'est vraiment une belle des
maires par les deux festivals aussi
tantôt je pense qu'un extraterrestre
pourrait montrer inquiet et francofolies
le tir ouais j'aurais à faire de même
je pense que ça nous représente bien ce
qu est ce qu on m a pas d'exode
est ce que pour toi le tournage de
battre c'est maxime c'est une expérience
qui était vraiment différent de au
tournage que deux vécus ou c ou ou au
contraste est très familier et mais je
dirais un mélange des deux parce que tu
aimais tant faire un film de xavier s'il
veut pas senti fait quelque chose de
d'importants quel sport une bonne
bordure mais porter oui mais où city
comme tout le monde qu'il a été honoré
des clubs qui content d'être le pij
je pense que ça devrait tout le temps
est comme ça sur un plateau le petit
comme jamais les gens devraient être le
faire chier mais xavier tellement ils
créent ou 6 et asthme cette atmosphère
le sur le plateau fac
tout comme l'impression de participer à
quelque chose de grand
fait que c'est quand même vraiment
spécial
mais en même temps vu que on est une
gang d'amis puis qu'on n'était et on est
toutes des supers amis proches dans la
vie fac test est en même temps très
famille l'ifac c'était parfait en fait
mon nom
si c'est moi où tu as une grosse année
maintenant voisine quand même une bonne
année ouais c'est ça qui est drôle parce
qu'il ya des gens qui me disent aussi je
vois des commentaires sur internet les
gens sont quand même structure on la
voit partout jusqu'au bout
ok mais tu aimais tant il ya des gens
qui me disent que je parte ou qui sont
tannés de m'avoir depuis que j'ai eu une
grosse année il ya quelques mois jean
raimbault deux salles et aux sports si
le gars qui me faisait payer idées comme
toi tu as déjà été comme et dernier
longtemps bon bah ouais mais tu es dans
un sas peu ça dépend ce que tu regardes
en vie mais je peux quand même on dîne
canet poste comme footing personnes j'ai
eu une bonne année parce que j'ai
travaillé quand même en fait j'ai
travaillé vraiment beaucoup mais ça
reste que je quand même content parce
que c'est des trucs desquels cheville
rpg travaille avec des amis cgpo mg pas
travailler 24 heures sur 24 des enfants
qui me faisait chier puis facois et je
suis plutôt que j'ai eu une bonne année
c'est ça bien commencer l'année passée
justement avec can't be c'est sûr que ça
ça crie comme une espèce d'aura de west
ham et on se passe rien d'autre cette
année là c'est quand même
exact mais ça arrêtez cela tu es allé à
cannes 6 har homa godard astralis piste
tellement puissant bras et moov a ussi
jaouen finalement de plus la fla jean
patrick bernet à chiconi colonnes ça
passe à travers l'écran et non c'est
fini que tu avais labo et allaitement
tyan pour moi c'était ouest est un rêve
et c'est quelque chose que j'ai en fait
c'est qu'elle de aussi de xavier il va
depuis tellement d'années puis on le
suit à distance puis on le regarde sur
l'ordi puis on attend qu'elle fasse des
tapis rouge puis c'est vraiment de
meetic pour nous aussi par rapport à
examiner moi je l'avais accompagné en
2000 quand il était jury au festival je
parlais avec lui puis je me rappelle je
regardais par la fenêtre de son hôtel
c'est qu'ils donnent sur karaca puis je
regardais puis je me disais un jour
j'aimerais c'est le cas voir rapporter
être là pour moi mais pour moi mais
naissance avec un film qui quatre ans
plus tard je pense on était là puis on
vivait son ensemble avec lui avec notre
homme avec mes meilleures amies sac
oui c'est mythique parce que c'est calme
depuis qu'il sait c'est le cinéma le thé
dansant
c'est le festival le plus important oui
eux mais en plus le stade lviv
on a entre amis qui d'être ensemble
d'être là pour vous aviez qui présentait
son film puis deux c'était vraiment fou
le tiche j'espère leur vive dans ma vie
mais comme c'est impossible je leur vive
de cette manière le sas et solidaire à
key west est vraiment fou mais c'est sûr
que c'est beaucoup comme tu dis de
flafla le petit je veux dire c'est quand
même un petit peu et par an le seuil de
voir la richesse des gens là bas puis
mais c'est ça c'est que parallèlement un
festival avec ciném'aude de la plus
grande qualité avec avec tmp avec le
prix le plus prestigieux au monde en
cinéma palmas est aussi les vedettes les
gros bateaux play-offs ardemment mt
mexique et cela va du festival
finalement vraiment oui parce que
l'année qu'on étale avec le film j'ai vu
aucun film apporte face maxime puis on
avait le temps vient porter les gens qui
comme vous avez dû faire le party c'est
comme non pas un peu mais c'est le matin
on travaille et on avait dit photoshoot
on avait des entrevues c'est la journée
et tu passes à faire des entrevues au
complet c'est une journée complète notre
vue je pense que j'ai bu un café puis
j'ai mangé genre un but de croissant de
toute ma journée était comme c'est
vraiment vraiment intense mais l'année
où jusqu'à aller avec xavier où il était
jury j'avais bu france
dix films puis l'on avait fait de la
partie on est allé sur les bateaux plus
solides
c'est comme l'eau j'avais vu cette
espèce de cannes l'a un peu indécent
picole oui oui mais quand un film la
botte est vraiment là pour le travail
tactique entre que nous on était
vraiment concentré sur est tranchée pis
la troupe qui j'ai vraiment une passe
israël a fait une tristesse pour le
monde qui aimait tant qu espérait
peut-être envoyer leur film la star ni
d'y penser comme égoïstement disant mon
dieu ça avait été l'année de mathias et
maxime jeu je n'arrêtais console
artefacts gym je peux même pas imaginer
les gens baye moussé budget serré pâquis
quoi l'amérique est très très proche de
moi qui se faisait par les prédateurs se
dit très très bonne chance il va avoir
lieu dans le sens qu'il va avoir le jury
va se réunir où ils vont se réunir par
skype ils vont regarder les chaînes
chacun leur bord puis ils vont donner
vie
il sait se confirmer moi je pense que
oui c'est pas alors qu'ils avaient fumé
sa loi intérieure et sérieux jeter comme
ben c'est ça c'est ça non mais c'est pas
et je passais pour être technique je
pense que c'est aux points et non pas
ici au sens du le barca ce par souci de
respect l'information exacte
quand même faille technique il ya
vraiment des pour rebondir la pudeur est
vraiment et des cookies comme week que
l'économie ralentit ce que bien des gens
qui perdent leur emploi ce si triste la
pelle mais il ya certes un coût qui car
j'ai vu la nouvelle tombait monjuste
décrit ses causes
mais n'est ce pas là aussi les jeux
olympiques c'est les jeux olympiques
sont reportés un an pour monsieur madame
tout le monde attaque assassine
hypo grandes choses c'est assez le ce
reporter ça met les mêmes athlètes on
voit tout le temps toute façon moi
j'avais vraiment une pensée pour les
gens qui étaient en fin de parcours
dernières années cuisine dernières
années toutes dans le même sens tout
dans le même panier pour aller aux
olympiques jo c'est le rêve d'une pop
qui ne vit si c'est vrai d'une vie sévit
maintenant les artistes qui perd des
gays ou même un festival c'est comme au
quai le ton ton film sera peut être pas
pris mais je dirais il va tenter
n'existe qu'en maritime avoir quand même
une autre une autre vie après ce timide
pour certains athlètes s'est terminé
comme ceux à mon dieu si ça fait rire
tout ce qui est arrivé ça fait 20 25 ans
tu t'entraînes pour ce jeu et est all-in
ça fait sept ans que les sacrifices tout
pour les olympiques c'est exactement la
même chose parce que cet athlète sûrs
que paul iv en lever tout son parcours
toute sa vie plus de temps c'est comme
alors même chose pour un cinéaste we son
film va exister puis va avoir une vie
sûre qu'elle met tantôt une chance
peut-être dans une vie d'alcan à la can
nous autres et niaiseux mais on avait un
court métrage on ne fait un court
métrage lieu l'été passé parce qu'on
voulait faire un regard sur le court
métrage qui doit le festival a acheté ni
puis on était tellement heureux parce
qu'on avait été pris ce puits
on est en chemin pour chicoutimi puis le
festival été annulés à cause de la
vilaine qu'ovide son court métrage ce
programme on a tourné ça en deux jours
puis mettez on s'était dit waouh c'est
le moment où les gens vont voir notre
court métrage en salles on va entendre
la réaction des gens pillent cyrielle si
un court métrage fac pauvres est
évidemment le premier réflexe comme me
mais après pauvres et les deux pré
rapport c'est que j'ai eu c'est calme
puis les olympiques parce que je me
demande c'est le travail d'une vie saine
c'est vraiment c'est les enfants qui me
font le plus de permettre et puis c'est
sûr que mettons dans mon cas pour les
olympiques parce que je peux facilement
mettre dans ces situations le laitier à
plus petite échelle si tu m'avais dit ma
dernière année deux semaines avant que
maintenant parce que c'est les aisselles
et b qui ont des camps clp vraiment 12
semaines à max a eu lieu sur l'hexagone
on est la compétition pour laquelle est
en train d'inventer un genre c'est
terminé bon c'est quoi si mettant comme
leçon de reporter mais qui s'est passé
pendant cette année ne soit pas de
casser une jambe droite a cassé un doigt
ou juste juste à vie mais dont ta vie or
c'est sur la forme parce que c'est là
que je vois la différence maintenant
entre entre une carrière artistique une
carrière d'athlète c'est que c'est ta
vie d'athlète et est finie c'est comme
un mec tu peux tu peux pas rejeté par
une taille 40 ans et si ça se fait par
l'un de ses fans
peut-être qu'elle est là la vie
reprendre son cours puis mon fort que tu
finisses diversité pictures athlètes
performants
la vie d'athlète
la vie d'athlète cccc du difficile la
vie de sacrifices c'est une vie par rich
non plus betv pour une chose il a aussi
comme acquis mettons je m'étais dit ces
jeux olympiques là c'est autre chose
l'année d'après tout était prévu mais
retournent aux études ou tu avais prévu
comme ça c'est parce que tu mets tout
les reste de ta vie se repose le camp
situé allée aux olympiques d'après ce
après
vingt-cinq heures ou 30 ans pis il fait
juste commencé et puis toute faute à qui
trouvera après le fait que c'est comme à
qui est ce que je me rabats quand ça
n'allait plus avant de m'embarquer dans
mon après les grosses questions le tpiy
mais c'est ça qui a et ans avec le sport
en général mais tant qu on oublie la
colle ville depuis on oublie comme c'est
la mode en ce moment
mais quand est une athlète de ce pareil
tout le temps que si ce qui fout moi
c'est ce qui est autant que j'admire le
sport puis que j'adore le sport en
général tj transporter puis j'aime ce
qui met autant que je trouve que quand
tu es un athlète je prends la décision
ou même pas parce que des fois t'es
tellement jeune que à un moment donné tu
pourra plus vivre de ton affaire qui
passionne c'est ce que je trouve je
trouve ça vraiment élevé quand même du
passé peuvent s'est pas dit si je
voudrais faut c'est vraiment je sais pas
si l équivalent en france elle est
l'expression fiscale famille c'est soit
quand même c'est soit tu vis
millionnaire en faisant du sport ou soit
été suivie de subventions la subvention
est un peu trop savoir comment dans
l'état vie puis quelqu'un sa stricte de
plumes scènes qui font du commande qu'on
soit un gouffre et lumière dans un
bureau est excellent et que c'est six
fois une agriculture non non comment
dieu ok mais comme un devis passion que
j'ai découvert pendant la cabine
c'est serré sans que ces gens cette
année c'est sur netflix pisser c'est en
fait c'est un documentaire sur une
équipe de tubes et qui s'appelle navarro
faxer comme perdu dans le fin fond du
texas
mais pour une raison x c'est devenu la
meilleure équipe de cheerleading métier
de cheerleading athlétique le post jean
de dieu n'est vrai qu'on peut détruire
puis suivent cependant je pensais six
mois leur travail pour aller à la plus
grosse copie de chiquita détourna et
c'est m
en bon parce que justement les
personnages étaient jean lily tubes sont
tellement intéressant qui choisissent
des gens avec des bagues ont un peu
trash puis comment le sport ils se
sauvent et puis comment justement après
l'université ça existe culture qu'est ce
que tu fais après puis pourquoi je
travaille aussi fort malgré le fait que
tu sais que ça peut pas être ton métier
dans l'âme hippie à mon dieu c'est
tellement bon faut que vous écoutez ça
c'est incroyable j'ai rien tout les
épisodes puis justement je pensais à
rien parce que c'est sûr qu'à la grosse
compétition de détonnant a été annulée à
cause lakovic je me dis justement si je
ne la que c'est leur dernière année de
tueur puis que m ont jamais fait la
compétition pu classer leurs chances
betty c'est fini toi tant que comédienne
dessus un peu ce feeling le kiki pas au
top est tout bonnement ouais quand même
quand même des métaux comme tu vois
stany est en fait il ya je devais partir
pour la france et je voulais me trouvais
à linge en labo mais évidemment tout le
monde ces crises bien évident de ces
nouvelles que viennent en france en ce
moment mais mais de façon je peux pas
sortir fait que parler mais tu vois ça
je me suis dit ah c'est peut-être
quelque chose du calvaire froid que je
fasse le deuil maintenant parce que
healy tj 29 ans le gie poe l'argument
mais je veux dire avec tout ce qui se
passe en ce moment je sais pas à quel
point et c'est ça va ce pouvoir il
aurait peut-être fallu que je fasse ça
avant le thé ira peut-être fallu que je
fasse ce mouvement a vampire baveux
poste une femme puis à partir d'un
certain âge tu es une femme actrice
boléro l'isf en moins intéressant puis
moins pertinent pis j'ose croire que ça
va changer mais tu es quand même c'est
sûr que plus tu vieillis en tant que
femme pim - les rôles sont cools peu
nombreux c'est moi j'ose croire que mon
ami je dois écrire puis que je vais
pouvoir mais si je veux travailler avec
des gens qui je travaille avec des amis
de toute façon fait que je me dis que je
vais je vais pouvoir avoir la chance de
travailler avec ces gens le toute ma vie
à tout le moins
puis je fais des doublages péter samol
juge pas non plus arrêter de travailler
dans dix ans mais quand même une
certaine elle vit tout a commencé
vraiment super g ou tps qui est-ce qui à
cet âge là à cette époque le moment tous
avec vous les faire se toute ta vie est
ce que tu pas être là encore françois 29
ans et quand j'ai commencé c'était non
le système vraiment plus ce genre comme
on fera que joachim löw c'était juste un
loisir qui j'avais pas une semaine puis
mes parents m'ont toujours est obligé à
avoir des bonnes notes à l'école parce
qu'il est comme ses fans ton avis il est
tellement vert s'agit tout simplement de
la charlotte
j'avais dit bonnes notes à l'école passe
ma mère puis mon pari pensé que j'avais
peut-être autre chose de ma vie
puis finalement non parce que en fait
c'est la preuve que j'ai fait un film
j'avais comme dix ans un père un nom de
charlotte
si j'ai passé plus de un jour sur un
plateau comme quatre jours en ligne de
plus j'ai réalisé que c'était un métier
on dirait que j'ai comme pony de quoi à
10 ans que j'ai fait aux attentes en ce
que je peux faire c'est toute ma vie que
je peux gagner de l'argent pis je peux
être à l'aise nauticom la réalisation
des deux côtés je ne pense pas ça le
plus tard parce que moi personne ne
parlait de hockey pee mère ni les
acteurs ni les accords et vieillissement
cia prennent de la maturité extrêmement
rapidement justement pour seul c'est
comme de dix ans tu es sur un plateau
pour le dédommager mais comme un athlète
j'imagine dans le sens que quand un
quota de dix ans tu te fais dire dans
quatre ans et les olympiques ces jeux
des rup à tapas le choix d'avoir une
discipline puis d'avoir un mining
nauticom une maturité pierre moi c'est
là que les entraîneurs viennent en place
l'outil prend la décision soit
l'entraîneur c'est la plupart des jeunes
athlètes sont vraiment bon c'est parce
qu'ils écoutent l'entraîneur sans poser
de questions le guide et leur prends mes
décisions
gaulle quand ils pensent pas à dispo
comme dans mon avenir c'est comme une
notion qui n'existe pas on dirait même
année je lis ouvert dix ans il me disait
assez cool mais tgv de deuxième année à
dos cette année de me faire reconnaître
j'ai mais comme tu fais que je voulais
je faire du doublage pris acte et j'ai
comme refroidie ce métier-là souvent
dans ma vie ce qui est une bonne affaire
à fort pour probablement tous les corps
de métiers tous les chaînes métiers de
faire de se remettre en question la
direction tu prends souvent j'aime
vraiment la formulation de prix de dire
j'ai reçu choisi ce métier leur souvent
je pense que c'est important de choisir
son métier souvent de faire le point de
frey est ce que c'est ça oui c'est ça
qui est beau ou même juste est ce que
c'est cette direction dans ce métier là
est ce que c'est cette fois que je
prends mais ce que 6e est ce que j'aime
ce que j'étais en train de devenir comme
artiste et mickey wever mais c'est un
peu comme les couples tait soit on
entend ce genre foutu sera choisi ça
tous les jours
j'ai pas moi ça fait cinq ans avec mon
film je savais pas et aiguisant les
découpes qu'il serait choisi ce vraiment
depuis dix ans était comme ben bravo par
part est ce que vous vous réjouissez
tous les jours eh ben c'est pas tous les
jours on n'est pas à notre place - ouais
ok c'est bon maintenant par dennis et
moi un choix c'est une obligation
j'imagine les bruits genre être pogné
avec la personne n'avait qu'à moi je
mets le nombre de courts métrages de
films qui m'ont fait ce nom s'écrit en
ce moment sur genre une fille rigueur
qui allait les sites sociaux moussa
blonde piano par des mythes des pagnes
arrêt pendant chez pas comme
intercession qui en est des gens qui y
vivent sont là
connais-tu la trilogie de films
il y avait une entrevue avec little rock
dans le fond mais pour ceux qui
connaissent port dans le fond c'est
l'histoire d'un couple ces trois films
qui se passent chacun à 9 ans
d'intervalle dans le premier film il se
rend compte qu'en deuxième film de votre
habitat mais si je lisais une entrevue
avec ethan hawke
l'acteur principal le subit il disait
dixit son quatrième film ce qui n'est
pas certain
ils vont essayer de briser le moule sais
pas ce qu'il dit j'ai baisé client en
fait le même film trois fois neuf en
internat et oui non mais moi j'ai jamais
fait préféré la bise et on va essayer
par des quads se faire appeler dit ça
serait drôle bien sans mais je sais que
des noms les deux personnages la mettez
les deux personnages poignée ensemble
genre en quarantaine pendant la pandémie
disco vide les plis telle hausse serait
pas une bonne idée
j'en parlerai des meilleurs pendant la
pandémie louis jeu ce genre de deux
semaines n'oublie jamais ses sauts ils
vont faire tellement de films là dessus
du genre sur toutes les situations
inimaginables
ouais ouais tu voi manquait aussi vont
avoir une espèce de vague de films
encore plus qui en avait déjà eu une
espèce de vague de films de fin du monde
ça peut qualifier directement
comment survit à ce genre de crise le
jeu
j'ai vu un mime récemment quitté comme
est si beau faire ils vont faire
tellement de films sur la coved laitiers
aux états unis pis ils vont tout le
temps faire que jean les américains se
disent souvent ont trouvé comme le
remède alors que dans les faits c'est
comme si la clameur des points qui place
le way exact c'est la turbie gamble mais
on reste en cela je le remarque
tellement qu'il ya tellement d'aléas
création artistique de jeunes on la
ressent je trouve la grosse la fin du
monde imminente pis si mal juste béton
juste projet 2000
c'est seul c'est comme la fin du monde
approche go et et des films au québec
ait eu à voir qu'on explose
oui ticket qui qui était un faux
qui la fin du monde approche et only
louangeant ça tourne parle de fatima
comment jusqu'au déclin les films
netflix le qui vient de sortir
non je n'ai pas encore vu non je
l'écouté dans les prochains jours et
c'est moi non plus j'ai pas encore vu
mais je pense c'est un peu seul à la
thématique exactement passé c'est andres
est vraiment maudit présent il est
clairement une angoisse le collectif
qu'on connaissait des textiles d'aider
des jeunes taureaux c'est très bientôt y
adonnent j'écoutais l'entrevue qu'elle
soit un par les genres et les devants
avec aymeric caron jean rené dufort et
idy clairement mot pour mot ce que ça
prendrait à l'humanité ce une bonne
pandémie iata 2010 n'est pas notre
conversation
ça me prenait une bonne part des milles
seulement pour moi mais après tout en
sachant pas trop ça pouvait arriver aux
dents de scie mais c'est fou par un bel
essai comme dwight schultz et dans des
offices qui diminue de nuke règle et
comme j'ai commencé les projets de
confinement c'est que j'ai finalement
commencé bien office n'avait jamais
quitté ce pays
c'est comme quand j'avais des séries que
neuf saisons j'étais comme je sais que
je vais aimer ce jeu ma partie là dedans
depuis neuf saisons est accroché juste
derrière fo koch 70 kg j'ai commencé ce
c'est drôle à tabarre mac c'est bon mais
j'avoue que c'est une bonne idée
d'écouter dix offices parce que c'est
comme c'est vraiment léger ça change les
idées pick up
ouais moi j'écoute axée sur une taxation
que ses moyens ses moyens légers mais
c'est apparemment c'est une des
meilleures séries qui est tellement
c'est bon maintenant succès incroyable
c'est comme un peu sur eux et ils disent
qu'ils sont expirés de voyons comment
s'appelle la famille entre une famille
super super riches aux états unis qui
possèdent toutes les gens qui possèdent
les nouvelles des blés des buildings des
parcs d'attraction des pis c'est
vraiment super bon succession sait où et
c'est sur quoi tu peux l'éviter belle en
plus c'est des bleus qui c'est gratuit
- toute une série sur corinne way pour
toujours 2 exact c'est bloqué c'est
gratuit
mais pour un mois je pense ok c'est toi
parce que tu peux aller de chez qui ce
mets ton est ce que tu veux plus faire
écran plat mais je pense que tout est
gratuit
c'est quand même le fun dabitch équipe
c'est une coupe d'affaires vraiment
intéressantes dont ce que ces chaînes et
pour toujours plus sous l'eau j'écoute
et j'écoutais faux départ gerard way
ouais vraiment téléphone c'est comme ces
belles ces patchs easy baisse et ça
c'est mon ami jean fait baril guérard
qui n'est ce pas recrache ehpad envie
c'est vraiment un lot de spare
intelligent puis vraiment vraiment faut
qu'ils y étaient déjà en fête puis 15
puis sera un peu comme que c'est trash
puis maintenant il écrit pour des
peuples je les ai lu que c'est comme un
système étant ce genre c'est quand même
le savez les gens ça y va par là le
député comme un voile puis andrei
kirilenko qui réalise pas que j'écris
autant de scènes de cul puis de scènes
trash qui fait chier rebond mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il est un style de de tv
qui n'existait pas à trouver un sens qui
s'y trouvent là c'est rod rajustement
c'est trop difficile mais le pyjama les
schémas of the web série c'est comme ça
paye a pas vraiment de limite que je
veux dire c'est l'fun d'avoir ce parce
qu'on on décompte établi à tous de voir
ça au québec 7 6 pts 2 séries de aussi
recruté sékouba souligner l'audace de
tou.tv puits devaient patienter je
dirais même si nous aimons content
maintenant ces grandes luttes et il ya
des subventions payées dit oui on
rêve faire une série avec deux pièces
qui la met n'importe où sur youtube le
texas fils mais tu vas avoir de l'argent
mais faut que les indices us investis
tout ça avec les gens chez tous points
tv ont quand même été vraiment audacieux
je trouve pas vraiment games vraiment de
la bonne du moment du bon qui sait à
tou.tv vraiment vraiment bon si je
trouve je trouve que les gens là bas
comme comprennent et on devrait avoir
plus de diffusion je comprends qu'à télé
publique blabla me dit mais je trouve
qu'il devrait aborder du sort qui compte
plus de listes en général le petit jeu
de je sais pas si vous avez vu c'est
pour ça que je t'aime la série oui
c'était françois létourneau pire ivoire
pour moi c'est des génies le tigre série
noire les investissements pour moi c'est
le meilleur série québécoise sur jamais
été fait
bissau le cette cellule puis tu sais
mais tant ce jeu trouve ça tellement
payant pis c'est juste sont tellement du
golfe puis ils vont tellement à fond
mais je pense que on devrait avoir plus
de cela qu'il y ait ce que est ce que
vous pensez que il ya une espèce de
pouvoir pour avoir ce genre de
subventions là pour faire ce que tu veux
ça prend une espèce de cv qui qui bien
blindé saison de deuil ont fait les deux
ces micro allemands les plus respectés
de la critique au québec est méritée a
livré avec une idée le permet on va
faire cellou estimant qu'ils puissent
même pas quatre pattes qui à part en un
amas 12 épisodes puis moi commente régis
ouais mais quand nous à faire aussi ces
bétons ci finance quand même un faux
départ il finançait fourchette des
niveaux projet du nouveau visage ou sic
et qu'il von finck
ouais ouais c'est ça la fin c'était en
télé télé je comprends que ça peut pas
être des affaires trop trash ok ok si ou
que ça mais c'est juste une idée
originale c'est comme c'est pour ça que
je t'aime
oui oui je pense que ça prend vraiment
un nom qui un cv pire c'est parce que
même même baril guérard titre il n'est
pas nulle part ils n'y arrivent pas
commun comme je veux ça super longtemps
qui roule sa bosse fait longtemps que la
critique il aime ce fait longtemps que
chaque héritier de guégan biais de
projet en projet et puis passez go aussi
la boîte avec sur le fait c'est eux qui
avaient fait chalet qui ont fait de
l'académie si le format que j'ai lu ça
aussi ça a dû lui imagine quand un truc
qui c'est sûr que pour les jeunes
créateurs en ce moment c'est trop facile
ne serait-ce que ans au cinéma je dire
pour avoir des financements bars et des
films faut que tu avais fait trois
courts métrages en circuit qui ont été
diffusées faut que tu ailles ici comme
s'étoffe de smet a créé de nulle part le
thé comme fiscaux ce que le web
justement bain ou permet je pense aux
gens de tester des affaires puis de se
faire un nom puis de ce qui est cool qui
est ce que c'était toujours dans
l'équation que ça lève toi python thiam
qui faisait les deux personnages on peut
désormais j'ai si peur je sais pas je
pense qu'ils se pensent que oui je pense
que mon personnage et jpy est où ta
pensé à moi mais je pense que je pense
qu'antoine c'est arrivé rapidement aussi
sauf que je pense qu'au début les gens
est un peu parti vu qu'on est qu un
couple dans le chalet qu'on a joué
ensemble dans une coupe d'affaires quand
même je pense que les gens se dire où on
veut vraiment mais quand je dis les gens
je vais ôter du pilat production test
ils disent que ça va être encore t mais
finalement ça rapidement si rapidement
devenu si c'est cool
du coup c'est vraiment un bon il
vraiment libre un bon je trouve ton
sommes là-bas en général mais la bâche
rookie au rebond mais je merci mais oui
bon ben moi je trouve que si cependant
tout ne cache pas
bien matin j'écoutais prélat l'épisode
des projets de m c'est trash en tabarnak
aussi le nom c'est comme si en dix
minutes de manhattan ces gens à 8 ans et
plus seraient pleinement vite et comme j
coûté 5000 ans sort de neuf ans et des
moins trash des projets d'aidé moi
j'adore ça
si vous jetez comme date american pie du
coup je sais pas quel point on va
devenir un classico même qu'une pâle
mais moi je trouve que c'est un peu dans
le même esprit le thé nostalgique et
pour ceux qu'on ait tout genre ben trop
vieux pour jouer nos personnages pitt
est un gros stack dommage le
complètement mais c'est un hommage à
babu beaucoup de chose dans le genre
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui s'en vient
si on croise les doigts tout l'été
existe et s'il était existait en fait si
l'automne existait aux hommes loto du
medrek une croix sur l'eau donne une
impression qui automne sa seconde suis
pas mal longtemps le très tatoué à la
bresle après tatoue moi ce qui m'a fait
pas acheter comme newton faut faire une
croix sur le thème patrimoine non en
fait mon htc qu'il ya des coupes la
parfaite disons que ya peut-être des
saisons 2 qui s'en viennent là en
général
puis c'est vraiment tout en deux si ça
si ça se passe
hier une coupe de saison 2 qui a
engrangé un tournage en juillet aussi
dont je peux pas t'en parler mais moi je
peux rien dire ces platanes le soin de
les voisins on était supposé faire les
voisins québec
la pièce de théâtre à québec albert rust
ofac et en ce que j'espère que ça va se
donner comme c'est ce que vous êtes en
juillet-août
mais moi je dispose être albert rousseau
ou septembre avec king kibboutz moi
juste lac tarder à jouer les séquences
et de suker cd complet
ouais mais georges parce que celle de
shaw ce montant ce moment pittis a
commencé à montréal en juin juillet
montréal où sap tarmac et b mais tout
cela tient aussi tellement horrible
ouais c'est sage postigo mais ouais
c'est plate c'est vraiment plate mais on
est dans un état de c'est la vie même si
la scène est si beau projet gérant
excité puis jean pigeon monétairement
s'est investie coussinets effect mais on
dirait que c'est en mode vie qui vers
d'autres mais est ce que tu penses que
ça se peut que ce soit l'année prochaine
je dis aux lillois qui en est un show
l'année prochaine bon ben vous falloir
il va falloir ça leur temps d'en faire
un dîner on sait rien c'est pau on sait
pas on se croise les doigts pour que
pour que ça continue pour que soit ils
rapportent tous soyons face à un hôte ou
soi mais on le sait ces papiers même
mois mettant ma place au sein d'un jeune
prodige espérait comme guitariste est
pas assuré le tir mais y avoir un show
devrait être déçu que les rabbins c'est
triste mais je comprends ce que tu veux
dire que c'est l'ami j'avoue que vu que
tout le monde et en break peu comme si
tu avais juste toi cela qu'il avait dit
a finalement désolé si quelqu'un d'autre
tout le monde est en brique l'exacte de
ses couleurs on dirait qu'ils sont moins
payés l'excès comme mandjeck c'est comme
un peu les boules
ouais avec toutes ces couleurs ces
gamins tout le monde fait ça pour tout
le monde je ne classerai pitayas exact
je me dis que je peux pas marcher à
l'issue
comparé avec d'autres dépoussiérant plus
difficile ou qu'ils perdent
témoin j'ai perdu des beaux contres mais
justement à perdre comme on disait
tantôt les olympiques ou car
incomparable
je mets toujours peas vient la raddho
mais sur un mot de la fin m quatre types
ans tu penses que le monde après la
crise ça va être quoi nature venez
exactement comme c'était où ça va
changer un peu à mon dieu mais selon ce
que je lis le team et ont d'après les
spécialistes jamais la main depuis j'ai
tendance à les croire dans le sens que
tu mets ton en asie après le strass puis
après le h1n1 et tous les choses ont
quand même changé pour le mieux dans le
sens que les gens après avait une
conscience vraiment plus grande de
l'hygiène
ces sicav mais mettons moi jamais
j'avais réalisé à quel point je mettais
mes doigts dans ma bouche on en vit ici
on a tous notre phase je crois que c'est
à dire toucher vos mots de passe
ce qu'on veut faire vraiment plus
attention dit qu'il va en des mesures
d'hygiène si pour les gens qui
travaillent dans les épiceries dans les
pharmacies dont l'ego rêveur mais je
pense parce que j'ose croire que aussi
on va t on parler de privilèges tantôt
puis de qu'on réalisait preuve certaine
d'affaires j'ose croire qu'on veut sans
rappeler qu' on va prendre c'est prendre
soin des gens qu'on aime puis on va
profiter de ces moments là aussi le pid
ses sicav même le chox en train de
belles et chaudes sur cuivre pour
toujours plus un jour c'est le genre une
chine laisse plug le met dans son siège
c'est un show sur un doute qui apprend
qu'il va mourir d'ici un an puis le
couple décide de vivre c'est tous les
jours comme si c'était le dernier le
parce qu'elle peut pas quand tu sais que
tu vas mourir durant ben tu fais des
affaires que tu aurais pas faites sinon
puis moi ça m'a vraiment et de tourner
cette série là ça m'a ouvert les yeux
sur prennent à faire puis deux et de
réaliser à quel point on remet les
choses à plus tard
on profite pas nécessairement de chaque
journée comment on devrait
j'espère que ce qu'on est en train de
vivre que nous donner comme mon espèce
de boost 2 on va avoir le goût
faire les choses était de créer des
choses de donner vie belle dune biblique
où elle a donné des bécanes aux amis
fidèles
je sais pas si j'espère entre que
savons-nous que savons nous aime nous
inspirer pour la suite
c'est vraiment un bon mot de la fin
j'allais rebondir sur des quads un petit
peu plus tôt mais je pense c'est
vraiment un trou et un moment de la
fonte en finesse ouais merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté des partis mais
sincèrement j'espère que les gens vont
aimer la conversation pour l'heure on
t'écoute pas tes lectures de délits j'y
vais au coup parfait remplaçant de l'esc
lille